okay i was browsing the david pakman
show subreddit this morning which of
course you can find at davidpakman.com
reddit we have surpassed 20 000
subscribers to the david pakman show
reddit one of the largest
independent progressive media subreddits
on reddit if you can believe that
uh a user posted an article called trump
has a point about the polls
from politico and the gist of this
article
is that there were some state polls
in 2016 that were wrong
and there were some state polls in 2016
that said hillary clinton was going to
win by a small margin and trump won by a
small margin
um and certainly that's true and you
know my my goal
on this show has been not to
um inaccurately assail polling more than
it
deserves but also not to hold polling up
as any kind of immutable
and unchanging metric that tells us
exactly what's going to happen
in november in 2016 the polls were
widely accurate
the national polls said hillary clinton
was going to win by three and she won by
a little more than two
that that means they were right they
were the results were within the margin
of error in most states they were right
it is true that when states are really
really close
uh sometimes state polling that is done
even
five days before um the election
may not reflect who is going to win that
state and certainly
michigan wisconsin and some other states
are examples of that so what we should
take away from this is not
that polling is widely untrustworthy
when we are talking about
highly rated pollsters it's
understanding that there's a margin of
error
and that things can change also in the
last
few days before an election so if it
tells us anything it's that no matter
what state
you're voting in you need to vote and
that no matter what the polls say
you need to vote that's the message and
there's no
you know there's no big revelation about
the the
uh particularly inaccurate polling in
2016 the polls were mostly right
nationally and at the state level the
polls
did not account for uh some um
momentum and swings in trump's direction
close to the end of
of the campaign and there were states
where hillary
was leading in the polls and she
ultimately lost what that tells us is
the polls give us a sense of what's
going on
but we need to absolutely crush turnout
to ensure
that trump doesn't end up winning some
of these states by 11 000 votes again
like he did in michigan that's the
takeaway
another post on the subreddit is about
youtube autoplay
uh pointing out that uh no matter how
many of
my clips people watch on youtube
they still get uh last week tonight
recommended instead of more david pakman
show clips
this is an ongoing issue with youtube's
algorithm we actually have a new
a really great study from mark ledwich
who has been studying this stuff
about exactly how the youtube algorithm
has hurt our channel it's an
excellent piece that mark did which i
i'll present to you when we have some
time it's not the most urgent thing but
maybe next week
i'll have a little time to talk to you
about it so
uh yeah youtube if you watch corporate
media
uh will recommend you corporate media if
you watch alternative independent media
like the david pakman show
youtube will still mostly recommend you
corporate media so
the best thing to do is you subscribe to
our channel on youtube you hit the bell
to tell youtube you actually want to be
notified you want to see
all of our posts in your feed and maybe
even via email if you want but don't
feel obligated to do that
that's really the best way to ensure
that you are not missing
our content lastly a user named bacon
and caffeine is criticizing my
pronunciation of
the state whose abbreviation is fl
saying david it's florida not florida
so i'm from massachusetts and
here unless you're from certain
neighborhoods in boston you
do pronounce it florida when i say
florida
i'm sort of joking that's the the new
york
accent way of pronouncing florida um
you know i uh i i am jewish and i do
have relatives who
have moved from from new york to florida
and
their pronunciation is florida i
understand
but both are certainly valid
pronunciations thank you
okay join the discussion at
davidpakman.com
reddit